vous avez un talent caché mais pas très
en fait si vous avez une voix très très
malléable vous avez imiter
extraordinairement bien et notamment
défaire des voix de cartoon politicien
[Applaudissements]
est en fait comme et lancé un appel
pressant vous auriez aimé en faire ma
demande y est
là c'est sa voix naturelle il a pensé
qu'on se demande si le battement d'aile
d'un insecte au brésil peut provoquer
une tornade au texas de quel effet
parle-t-on l'éphéméride
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
bon pas de réaction pas de réaction très
bien géraldine maillet dit moins encore
des leçons et bien moi j'aime bien
respecter un peu les français ont été
laissées par les vous fatiguer tout le
monde vous fait insupportable avait jeté
à l'eau je vous dis vous est
insupportable irradie tout le monde le
dit et on vous aime beaucoup vous est
insupportable tout le monde était heroes
français n'ont pas dû tout arrêter de
dire aux français si on peut faire ça
avait été de dire aux français il faut
faire si les français ils font ce qu'ils
veulent il s'avère que son véhicule et
ayant été revendus effectivement on n'a
pas pu lui réplique tu es donc on a lavé
l'affront non non tout à fait bien on
avait un bon de commande soulever non
attendez on va faire différemment parce
que là je vous assure que je suis je
veux aller me mettre une boîte entière
de support local est pucé me coucher
parce que ça commence maintenant bien
faire l'histoire
[Musique]
ils sont pas comme vous géraldine
maillet avec un salaire confortable avec
une très belle vie et parfois il ya des
français les super ma vie c'est d'un
ratio prêt il ya des français qui jouent
énorme et branches n'hésitez pas non
mais moi je sais ce que vous gagnez ici
donc je sais bien déconné c'est pas ma
vie j'ai 50 ans oui mais alors alors je
m'en réjouis mais les arrêter sur les
émotions arrêtez de donner des leçons qu
est-ce que vous avez surpris en point
mais c'est pas moi c'est pourquoi
laisser finir c'est pas un débat entre
vous et moi mais c'est fois de se gâter
les bouquets mais alors je parte soudé
tout le monde je me tais alors il y en a
parmi nous qui bavent bien plus que
d'autres il s'agit des bébés c'est
l'heure de
jeu explique le cassage de mes clients
premium il a du mal comme si j'ai un peu
de mal mais c'est pas un bon moment
comme partout c'est ça en fait compris
le truc en fait le kif elle n'a pas
compris que plus il y en a partout c'est
là les enfants s'amusent c'est là oui
c'est un motif et c'est là où tu viens
manger
[Musique]
à ses 18 ans cet américain reçu 1800
dollars pour s'être tenue à l'écart des
réseaux sociaux pendant son adolescence
c'est sa mère qui lui avait proposé ce
contrat à l'âge de 12 ans ironie de
l'histoire lorna la maman a publié des
centaines de photos de famille sur son
compte facebook pendant six ans silver a
tenu bon il y a eu des moments
difficiles mais ça valait le coup confie
aujourd'hui le jeune homme qui est
ouvert un compte instagram avec une
seule photo partager en un mois nous les
humains on veut parfois créer des choses
qui durent pour l'éternité mais je pense
que le changement est éternel on n'est
là que pour un certain temps
alors on doit profiter de notre vie sur
terre et après on repartira
c'est pas mal ça